this is what william and kate see as
service
they knew that abaco needed attention
after hurricane dorian
[Applause]
and at the same time showed us that
despite a week of criticism they are
determined to get on with the job to end
the trip william issued this
i know that this tour has brought into
even sharper focus questions about the
past and the future in belize jamaica
and the bahamas that future is for the
people to decide upon
he added catherine and i are committed
to service for us that's not telling
people what to do it is why tours such
as this reaffirm our desire to serve the
people of the commonwealth and to listen
to communities around the world who the
commonwealth chooses to lead its family
in the future isn't what is on my mind
strong words from a future king who
we're told has been listening
conversations with prime ministers in
all the host countries leading to last
minute changes to some of his speeches
it is striking to hear prince william
acknowledge so clearly that he believes
one day it may not just be commonwealth
realms cutting ties with the royal
family but also the wider commonwealth
and that's when you think just how
important that body of nations has been
throughout his grandmother's reign the
fact that he is also here representing
the queen also makes it more than likely
that his words have been endorsed in
some way from the top
forming new relationships was always a
big part of this tour yes there have
been protests but on our travels we
found the debate about breaking away
from the royal family isn't clear-cut
the royal couple come and pay us a visit
it has so much meaning to it
it shows that there are people out there
who are still very much concerned about
our well-being
and for a short while we were thinking
that everybody had forgotten us
i think the ties has been good with the
queen
and you know all through all my lifetime
so
there have been no major gaffes as such
from the couple themselves but following
the black lives matter protests claims
of racism from other family members and
the demonstrations over slavery just
this week it has felt like we are in a
new era of royal tours and william and
kate seem to sense that too
[Music]
rihanna mills sky news in abaco